la vida espacial de tomates que ha
captado la atención de franceses y del
resto del mundo el ascenso del
estrellato espacial de este hombre de 43
años lo ha convertido en una inspiración
para muchos desde el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón a una multitud de niños
curiosos en todo el mundo
mi pregunta es cómo cambias tu
percepción del universo a escala al
estar en el espacio y no solo es la
emoción de sus hazañas en el cosmos como
las caminatas espaciales para cambiar
los paneles solares de la estación
espacial internacional pues que es un
imán para los medios de comunicación
también ingeniero y piloto además de
música
o cinturón negro de judo y puede hablar
de todo esto en seis idiomas estas
cualidades no estarían completas sin una
causa por defender el llamado por una
mayor diversidad en la búsqueda de
futuros astronautas en europa radio mi
única reserva es que podría haber más
mujeres si el 50 por ciento de los
aspirantes fueran mujeres sería
fantástico pero quién sabe tal vez haya
más de una mujer astronauta francesa en
la próxima selección y tal vez en la
generación siguiente tengamos por fin
igualdad de género después de llevar a
cabo experimentos sobre el sueño el
envejecimiento cerebral y la radiación
durante los últimos cinco meses la
última misión de pesquet es asegurarse
que los otros seis tripulantes de la
estación espacial internacional sigan
realizando sus tareas hasta el final de
su estancia pues que regresa a la tierra
con un segundo logro ser el astronauta
francés con más horas espaciales
acumuladas en la historia